okay jordan we're gonna leave
wait what
it's quite heavy oh there i am
that's funny seeing myself
all right
this is um
this is my default setting this
loneliness
nah just been on my own only charred in
that this camera's heavy me
uh right so 15 minutes
eh i mean do i have to hold it the whole
time
maybe i'll just
perky down
how do i move you up
oh no i can't do that
oh
yes
that break the illusion
i'm ruining everything i can just i can
sense it i've already
oh
i already hit the mic
sorry mike
do my fashion show
no i can't do that
i'm not gonna go on my phone
because what would be the point
let me turn my jacket off
all right
maybe i'm gonna answer one of these
questions
i feel like i need to summon all the
energy
i'm you know i'm an energetic person
really this is a comfy chair
ah the real the real thing is i talk to
myself all the time so i can't
differentiate with when i'm aware that
people will watch this or whether i'm
just talking to myself like usual
maybe someone is watching when i'm
talking to myself
wait what
okay
um
ani
lad
i need that
who was your first celebrity crush
a crush that's like a conscious thing
isn't it that's like that's active
the crush is active right
i have to consciously
i only say that because i'm sure my
first erection was watching the britney
spears hit me baby one more time video
which actually sends me into existential
crisis a little bit because i think to
myself i was so young
i must have been like six or something
how do i know that that's sexy
but my first celebrity crush consciously
i don't know
probably um
i'm literally i can't remember sorry i'm
just having to put i'm going to trawl
through just like years of
corrupt dirt
like
conditioning
trash just going through the trash
i'm not sure i can't remember probably
like a bond girl or something like that
or
you know
i think ashley and actually ashley and
fresh prince of bel airmen but but
only because she was like younger so so
it was like more
that's that weird
i mean i was like literally ten anyway
um i can't thank you guys first
celebrity i'm gonna come back to that
this is the thing with these 15 minutes
i could just sit here deliberating over
one question for all of eternity
what's your proudest achievement today
proudest achievement today
probably i'd um
i'd probably say in my mental health
campaign i was proud about if i am whole
it was supposed to be something small
and it s it really blew up and i there
was this
this hashtag this hashtag i'm whole
seeing thousands and thousands of
songs
seeing thousands and thousands of people
[Music]
utilizing the hashtag to talk about them
kind of
open up about their mental health and
like that i thought was
great and i remember feeling this kind
of transcended
i felt like served servitude certitude
how can i talk
serving my community or serving the
community i think i feel is is an
unparalleled
transcended feeling
and i got close to it with with
opening up a space or being part of a
a movement that led people to
feel more connected that's that's
that's incredible it's an incredible
feeling
[Music]
and i'm also proud
that
as a
teenager me and my mate you know
set our minds to something worked hard
and then
sold a ton of records
i'm very proud of
rizzle kicks
getting to the level it did although i
might have waited a bit because i was
a kid
um
a young man
yeah i mean i'm still young let's be
real
yo check this out look at these okay
should we film the other camera and then
break the matrix
oh auto focus
hi my name is jordan stevens and today
i'm going to tell you guys how to
uh
this is a tutorial on how to be alone
jump
cut i don't want to be i don't know i
really i want to get into youtube
content creation i just need someone
just to explain it to me
look at that red dot
recording forever everyone is recording
at all times constantly
i can't sit
still must be quite annoying actually
also i keep looking at my reflect i keep
looking
this is life now isn't it how do i turn
this away i can't turn it away because i
need to see the frame
what's your favorite thing about your
girlfriends
oh what i love this question
how do you know i've got a girlfriend
i'm telling you man they're spying on us
what the [ __ ] is going on
all right
i can tell you
luckily i can tell you my favorite thing
about my girlfriend
um because
she's great
there's a lot of things i like about my
girlfriend
i
i
she is
she takes the piss
a lot she takes the piss
we have a good
we have a good back and forth in terms
of rinsing each other and you know like
i said roasting each other roasting each
other
uh
but i've said this before actually my
favorite thing about my girlfriend is
she's got three different smiles and
laughs
for different occasions
and they're so alive you know like i can
it the reaction time to to an event or
to a sentence or to something on telly
or whatever is that he brings out these
different loves and smiles and there's
just like these these incredible forces
of energy and they feel so pure to the
point where i can like you know
the buzz goes back and forth
but i just love it i loved one laugh
particularly just just like really fills
me with joy
what's the best and worst thing about
being famous
i don't even know if there is a best
thing to be in favor i mean i suppose if
you're famous you have
you have visibility that you can utilize
it depends how you define fame man like
anyone could be famous
literally anybody can be famous
you know i could like
i could i could do something horrific
and be famous
um
yeah utilizing influence i suppose is an
important thing
but the worst thing about being famous i
suppose is that you
you know
you ha you you lose you lose your
privacy you lose a part of yourself that
i think is
imperative to
to being a human being you need you lose
connection with
i don't know quiet and
sometimes you're looked at as as an
object
people will talk about you too like when
they're in front of you like it's crazy
but you also i suppose we're famous no i
mean there are things there's perks for
fame you know there's this thing in this
in society where people are into
hierarchy so you can just make someone's
day just from like being
there and then they just like give you
free
that's mad to me i mean
a lot of celebrity culture i think i'm
massively into but
i mean yeah i suppose that would be a
perk of fame it's just like getting free
stuff
but i'm not even sure if that's fair
i what i wonder sometimes why we
datify people to the extent that we do
when i often think
you know fame isn't a measure of success
where do you see yourself in 10 years
time
in the woods
i'm gonna be in the woods in 10 years
all right off grid with my girlfriend
and my dog if she agrees
[Music]
um
[Music]
don't should be out i want to be out of
this i want to be off
i want to detach from
the allure the abuse of my impulses like
let me be free man
well give me the purest illusion of
freedom which is like i don't know
enough passive income to not need to be
everywhere all the time
or just like learn those ultimate
survival skills and just go into it or
realistically in 10 years i don't know
but but i'll we'll be near or in nature
i'll you know i'm already by the sea
maybe that question was about my career
i don't know
i'll be writing i'll be writing
if you're a video game character which
one would you be crash bandicoot 100
i'm a mess
actually that's quite a nice little
addition to
i've been told i can roam around if i
want
i've been told i can roam around the
office but
i don't know if i want to man i quite
like being in rooms on my own
it's a powerful space to be in
like when first lockdown hit last year
i remember thinking
this is normal to me
this is my teenage years
okay
[Music]
okay more questions i like questions
if you could punch any celebrity in the
face who would it be
oh my god the list is too long to count
listen
i know i want to say
ah
yo got to be fair about this though
because
there are people i would want to punch
but i don't know them you know
and that's kind of ridiculous
and part of the problem often
assumptions on people based off of what
i've seen or i've been allowed to see
so the real question is of all the
celebrities you met who would you smack
and the answer is
i'm gonna come back to that one
the suspense
what was your first star strap moment
and with who
okay listen so when i grew up right i i
believed for whatever reason that
you shouldn't idolize people that
idolizing people was to
in some way
play into the idea that you yourself
were not capable of meeting that people
those people at that level right so i
would say to myself i'm not going to go
and ask for a picture i'm not going to
bug someone or i'm not even going to
feel a thing
until i i can step into a space with
that person and they recognize me and i
recognize them and we can con converse
from that level that was what i always
thought from when i was really young
um
however once rizzo kicks popped off yeah
i do remember there's one point where i
went to some like the games launch and
other musicians was kind of like cool
you know at that time reality television
was starting to pop off a little bit i
mean that's how he looked we're knocking
about
but it was a footballer it was daniel
sturridge actually nathaniel sturridge
when i first
when i first met him
it tripped me out just because i'd just
been playing fifa that day with him he
was literally on and i was like i've
just scored of you in a video game how
am i looking at your face now and then i
and also i was such a big football fan
him and kieran gibbs were having a
conversation about football and
sturridge was like yeah you know i like
arsenal and i'm like wait what i gotta
read like
gossip like gossip on the internet to
figure out whether or not a player wants
to come to a football club they're
talking to me about foot real football
big man football talking about managers
and like england managers and
it was crazy so that was wild i'm not
sure if i started but i was definitely
baffled but the real one was will smith
mainly because he's actually my real dad
and i i can't believe it took me
getting to the men about three premiere
to really meet him
your time is up jordan oh okay great
thanks
you'll never you'll never get to
find out who i'd punch in the face
well i'll let you know that they are
famous
what's your head in the mic yeah so
so quick
oh my god
[Applause]
why jelly who came up with that as
disgusting